-Let´s just jump right into
the awkwardness
of writing a book
about your life.
Was that a hurdle
for you to get over
to open up and tell
all these stories to people?
-I´ve been able to hide
behind characters for my career,
which has been such a luxury.
And then I thought,
"Well, you know what?
You know, maybe I have
something to say," you know?
And I could tell people about
how lonely I was growing up
or how insecure I felt
or jealous or whatever.
And so I thought,
"I´m gonna write a book."
[ Sighs ]
[ Laughter ]
-How quickly into it
did you feel that deep sigh
that you just gave us?
-[ Chuckles ] Pretty quickly.
-Yeah.
-And now that it´s coming out,
I´m really proud of it,
because I hope that --
I don´t know.
The idea of,
like, a collective experience,
like, the insecurities
that we all face.
-Yeah,
I think a lot of people --
-What are your insecurities?
-What are my insecurities?
-Mm-hmm.
-I certainly -- growing up,
I had nothing but insecurities.
Like, I felt very --
-Like what?
-What? Like what?
-Yeah.
-Like, I didn´t -- I could--
I had stage fright.
I didn´t get onstage until --
I´d never wanted to do school
plays or anything like that
until I was, like,
late in high school.
-I was known as the short kid.
Like, that was my identity.
And I think that everyone has,
like,
that sort of the adjective
that described them.
So, what was yours?
-Oh, what was the adjective
that described me?
-Yeah. Like...
-It´s not an adjective,
but I think "Braces"
would have been a very good...
[ Laughter ]
-I was "Headgear."
-You were "Headgear"?
-I totally trump you.
-Yeah. Did you actually
wear headgear to school?
-Yeah.
-No!
-Oh, God,
it was the worst mistake.
-How bad were your teeth?
-Lacy was going to --
She was like,
"You´re headgear girl.
I´m gonna kick your ass."
-Well, Lacy was very bad
at nicknames.
[ Light laughter ]
"Oh, you have a headgear.
You know
what we´re gonna call you?
´Headgear Girl.´"
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh, God.
Now I´m shaking.
-Yeah, I remember once going --
I had so much anxiety
about going to parties.
And I think the first time
I got invited to a party,
I was asking my dad,
"What should I wear?"
And he helped me pick out
an outfit,
and then I went,
and I realized that
I was dressed the way my dad
would be dressed at a party.
[ Laughter ]
-Like what?
-Like, everybody else
was in jeans and T-shirts,
and I was, like, with a sweater
tucked into khakis.
[ Light laughter ]
-Ohh. I love that.
-With the belted khakis and...
-And you got laid, right?
-I did not.
[ Light laughter ]
Although it would have been
a very inappropriate age
to get laid.
[ Laughter ]
So thank God.
Thank God I dodged that bullet.
And you -- this was sort of --
I mean, you had a platform
of doing this podcast.
So your podcast "Unqualified,"
as well,
and you take --
you give people advice.
-Which is...unbelievably absurd
because I have no idea
what I´m talking about.
[ Laughter ]
But...
-And you´ve let people know that
by the title of your podcast.
You´re not claiming
to be an expert.
-I try to --
I try to reinforce it.
-Yeah.
-Over and over.
-And what sort of issues
do people want your advice with?
-Well, they, you know, people --
we talk to --
I started the podcast
because I wanted to kind of talk
to strangers.
-Uh-huh.
-Without the format of --
of Hollywood or fame.
-Sure.
-Or, you know...
-Yeah.
-...just as creepy people do.
-[ Laughs ] Yeah.
-But, so people -- so we --
we talked to people about --
our most common themes
tend to be,
"Why doesn´t he or she like me?"
-Okay.
-But we´ve now -- we´ve had
some pretty interesting callers.
Recently, we had a woman who had
a threesome with her fiancé...
-Uh-huh. Uh-huh.
-...and a woman
that they met on Facebook.
And the woman called up a month
later and said she was pregnant.
-The -- The extra woman.
The third woman?
-The third woman.
-Oh, God.
They did -- Oh, it was you?
[ Laughter ]
-40! Still got it!
-Wow. That -- What kind
of advice do you give there?
-Oh, I was
[Chuckling] totally speechless.
-Yeah.
-I mean, what do you say?
But, you know,
I think I was just asking her,
like,
"Are you and your fiancé okay?"
Because, in my book,
I talk about things that
sound better than they are.
-Uh-huh.
-And one of them
is having a threesome.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Have you had a threesome?
-I´ve never had a threesome.
-Ohh.
-I almost did,
but they said, "Khakis?"
[ Laughter ]
That close.
Khakis were the deal-breaker.
[ Applause ]